thank you all very much for being here
today i want to take some time
to address nevadans about where we are
in our fight
against covet 19. i want to be up front
and talk to you directly because since
the start of this pandemic
i promise to be honest with all of you
to lay it out
you deserve that and i know nevadans can
handle that
so today i'm going to take some time to
lay out where we are
where we may be headed and what we can
do
first off i want to be clear right away
i am not here to announce capacity
limits
or closures or anything like that in
fact everything we're currently doing is
aimed at preventing
just those scenarios every vaccine event
every mask we wear every effort state
and local officials and partners are
making
is to protect not only your health but
nevada's economy
our businesses your jobs and our quality
of life
in a moment i'll walk through some of
the steps i'm taking to make sure we
don't go back
but first i want to address something
else
i know everyone is frustrated i am too
this pandemic puts us all in an
ever-evolving situation
that can result in roller coaster of
do's and don'ts
and changing guidance i know that can be
tough
especially when we were all starting to
feel a lot better
i know many of you felt that first
frustration recently
when we had to impose the mask
requirements based on new cdc
recommendations
for individuals vaccinated or
unvaccinated
in counties with high levels of covid19
transmission
unfortunately almost all of the silver
state is considered to have high levels
of transmission
trust me the last thing i wanted to do
was to require nevadans to put their
masks back on
especially those who did the right thing
and rolled up their sleeves
to get their shots but at this moment in
time
with the delta variant raging through
our state we need our mask as a bridge
to mitigate the spread and buy more time
as the vans get fully vaccinated against
covid19 and let me be clear
vaccines are the way out of this
pandemic
they are the way out of the pandemic
when we rolled back our mask mandate in
may
delta was less than one percent less
than one percent
of the cases today delta is greater than
ninety percent
of the cases in nevada and according to
the cdc
vaccinated people exposed to delta may
be as contagious as the unvaccinated
but have much less severe symptoms
i understand that this is frustrating
but the unfortunate reality is that
whether we like it or not
this virus mutates and we must evolve
along with it to protect not only your
health and safety
but our economy and our jobs
let me put it this way imagine covet 19
like a hurricane
i know we don't see many of those in
nevada but bear with me for a second
if you live in an area prone to
hurricanes there's a common
understanding among communities
as to how you respond to different
categories of the storm
if it's a category one you may only need
to take a few precautions
making sure your house is watertight and
finding some spare batteries for the
flashlight
but as the category of the hurricane
changes so does the response
you've moved gradually to battening down
the hatches with sandbags
and eventually evacuating the area
completely
as the hurricane approaches landfall the
category may change
depending on a number of factors as a
category of hurricane changes
so does the response on the ground in
nevada a more apt analogy might be
wildfires
as condition on the ground change our
firefighting efforts make headway or
wind shift
our response efforts change as well
northern nevadans are used to this kind
of a response
they understand that due to factors out
of our control
the situation may evolve and a response
must evolve as well
in order to keep ourselves and our
families safe
we've got to think about covid19 in the
same way
this virus has continued to change and
mutate
and our response must change and evolve
as well
we started with the original virus and
now we're facing the delta variant
and it is spreading like a wildfire
our response has to change to meet the
moment
that's why the mass mandate is back in
nevada
mass will help us slow the spread while
more nevadans get the vaccine
i understand that this feels like a
roller coaster to so many nevadans
in the first year this pandemic we were
without the vaccines
and our measures to fight the virus were
imperfect we implemented restrictions
and when numbers got better we loosened
restrictions
when restrictions loosened the cases
went back up
and so on and so forth it was disruptive
to everyone's life
we don't want to operate in that world
again here's the great news
we don't have to unlike previous waves
of this virus
we have a real solution this time the
covid19
vaccines that's our solution
the vaccines are incredibly effective at
preventing
severe illness hospitalizations
and death from coven 19. in nevada
almost every covet 19 death that we have
seen since january
of 2021 has been in the case of an
individual
who is not fully vaccinated again
almost every death we have seen since
january of 2021
is in individuals who have not been
fully vaccinated
we've been hearing a lot recently about
breakthrough cases
people who are fully vaccinated but
tested positive for covet 19.
this has led to people wondering whether
it's even worth it to get the vaccine
the answer is a resounding yes it's
worth it
because while reports of breakthrough
cases may seem
increasingly frequent the vast majority
do not end up
having a severe disease and as we see
vaccinated patients are not ending up in
the hospital
and are not dying from covet 19 we know
the vaccines are working in fact
nationwide
the rate is the rate of hospitalization
from breakthrough cases
is below point zero zero four
percent that's four one thousandths
of a percent and the rate of death is
under point zero
zero zero eight that's eight ten
thousands
of a percent about the same as the
annual risk of dying
from drowning if you're still not
convinced by the fact that vaccines are
still our most powerful tool against
covet 19
and its variants because they protect
against hospitalization and death
let me reinforce another reason why
vaccine is the only way to bring an end
to the pandemic
i have spoken at length about nevada's
balancing act
and about the delicate and vulnerable
position our state is in
because of the pandemic just like last
year our economy is not as diversified
as other states our largest industry
of hospitality and tourism is based upon
visitors
feeling confident to come here to visit
this industry our hospitality industry
keeps hundreds
of thousands of nevadans employed and
keeps a roof over their heads
it supports countless small businesses
and funds their state budget
so we can provide services like
education
and mental health care our economy has
started to come back stronger
and begin to recover and while we have a
lot of work to do
thousands of nevadans are back on the
job i want to continue
on that trajectory is your governor
it is my job to consider all of this and
to ensure i'm making decisions
not just based on today but also based
on what could happen to our state in a
few months
if we don't get this right because
frankly
there is no other state in the country
where striking this balance is more
challenging
or where the consequences are more
severe in getting it wrong
let me let me be clear on one more thing
this isn't just about our visitors it's
about an event
it's about jobs it's about going to the
homecoming or the prom
seeing your children's dance recital
or attending a school play
is being able to protect our quality of
life
and the things we love to do right here
in our state
it's about our families as i walk
through the steps i'm taking
i want to assure you that they are all
aimed at protecting the things that we
love
and i'm asking all of you who have yet
to get vaccinated
to please join this effort myself and
other officials
will do everything we can but we need
all nevadans to meet us halfway
do it for nevada
unless we increase our vaccination rates
quickly the virus will have time to
mutate again
the unvaccinated will continue to fill
our hospitals
and place unnecessary strain on our
ability to treat all patients
and their economic progress will be
threatened as a result
that's why we're masking up to slow the
spread is more than events
as soon as possible roll up their
sleeves and get their shots
and here are the steps to take his
status taking
in these efforts to continue our
recovery
to avoid rollbacks and to make sure we
can all continue
our progress this week i sent a request
to my medical advisory team
for recommendations in three areas
first i'm asking my medical advisors to
look at vaccination requirements
for all students attending in-person
classes
at our public colleges and universities
under the nevada system of higher
education
subsequent to my request to the mat i
was made aware that the entry covet 19
task force
unanimously unanimously recommended that
the covet 19 vaccine be required
for those attending their institutions
assuming that my
medical advisory team is in agreement
with those on the nc task force
that believe this is necessary for
nevada's highest education institutions
to join the hundreds of colleges and
universities across the country
in requiring covid19 vaccinations the
nevada division of public health and
behavioral health
will bring forward proposed regulations
to the state board of health
for consideration public health
officials have already begun discussions
with the appropriate partners including
those at the system of higher education
to explore a mental implementation of a
timeline
that would consider how long it takes to
complete full vaccination
with the upcoming academic calendar
i want to ensure those returning to
campuses in the coming weeks
that this will have no impact on your
ability to return to classes
this semester if this is the direction
taken
health officials will work with inchi
and higher ed partners make sure any
timeline
is fair and is reasonable you should
expect a board of health meeting to be
agendized in the very near future
to address this second i'm asking the
medical advisory team for vaccination
recommendation
regarding those who work with vulnerable
populations
like those in institutional studies
settings those working with the homeless
community
and those working in our health care
system
these recommendations will help guide
conversations and actions
we can take moving forward and i'm not
afraid to take bold action
and i look forward to reviewing the
guidance and working with officials and
partners to implement
as necessary more updates will be
provided as a
review recommendations and begin
conversations with impacted parties
and local officials finally
i am asking these medical advisors to
look at how we can make large gatherings
safer
nevada is an incredible location for
concerts
sporting events and so much more
we have a lot we have a mass mandate in
place and i implore all nevadans
attending
a large gathering to take it seriously
and to keep their
masks on however
understanding that the delta variant is
more infectious than anything we've seen
before in this pandemic
and having thousands of people in indoor
settings many of whom are unvaccinated
is high risk for everyone that's why
i've asked for recommendations on how
these venues and large gatherings
can do this right and how we protect one
another
when i get these recommendations back i
will be working with local officials
event managers and operators of our
largest venues to discuss how they can
best
implement safety protocols we've all
seen private sector leaders
step up to help in these efforts that
i'm hopeful they'll continue
to work with us to accomplish these
goals without a government mandate
or another directive again this isn't
for our visitors
this is so wolf pack and rebel fans can
go to a game
so parents can watch your kids perform
in the school play
and so friends can see their favorite
artists in concert
it's so nevadans can enjoy the best that
this state has to offer
and our communities without the threat
of spreading a dangerous virus
as these recommendations come back
you'll be hearing updates from myself
and state officials
again our goal is to avoid rolling back
finally yesterday we released
requirements
and strong recommendations related to
masking
and testing and other mitigation
strategies for k-12 schools
hundreds of thousands of nevada school
children who go back to school
in the coming days and weeks and many of
them
are not yet eligible for the covet 19
vaccines
if children must be quarantined it
interrupts their education
it pulls them out of classrooms they're
at with their friends
means parents have to miss work
potentially affecting their employment
and their ability to provide for their
families
when adults get vaccinated they protect
those who can't get vaccinated
because children under 12 are unlikely
to become eligible
for a few more months we have an
obligation to protect them
and help ensure that they have a smooth
and successful school year
they missed so much last school year and
i don't want them to miss it again
this school year i want to again ask all
nevadans who have not yet gotten the
vaccine
to please consider doing so as soon as
possible
talk to your medical professional talk
to your friends
that understand the vaccine and have
gotten the vaccine
amid the surge of delta variant we had
our largest percent increase in first
doses
since early june and first doses climb
for the fourth week in a row
i'm so proud of that between july 25th
and august 1st almost 3.5 percent of
eligible
unvaccinated nevadans got their first
dose
that's a 21 percent increase from the
previous week
and higher than the u.s average of about
3 percent
you can visit envycovitfider.org to
learn more
and to find locations that are available
for vaccines